all right bobo
yes sir bobo where'd you grow up where
you from originally
oh i'm from los angeles i'm from
venice beach venice okay village
california
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents yes sir
um well my my dad
well i was just chatting a while ago he
moved and went to
louisiana my mom got married
i was second married i think second
third marriage
and uh my stepdad okay as
i was a kid growing up they was always
arguing and fighting and then by me
being like
what five or six years old you know how
you get scared and nervous when you see
grown people fight what not that's
that's the problem that
i went through as i was going outside
doing a lot of you know playing running
around with the with my
friends and stuff there's this one
mexican dude
older cat and he like the young boys
so he used to call me bo come here come
in
i got some money to give you and i
believe that
by me being young like i used to be
right
so i went over there and see what he
wanted he took me in the garage
he said come here and i'm looking at him
like
with his clothes off i'm like something
wrong with this picture but i'm not
knowing about me being five or six years
old
i'm not really knowing like what's
really going on i'm thinking you know
by us living so close to the beach area
that he's changing his jaws when not to
put something else on to go swimming
they had me go you know go out there go
swimming with us
with his name with his kids and nephews
and cousins and stuff like that
right because we at that time that was
the people
uh his kids i used to play with a whole
lot
so he got up on top of a bench or
something
and his penis was hard and he had a
towel over it
and he asked me put my mouth on it
and i was scared i was shocked
i'm not knowing what's going on you know
and i'm looking at this like put my
mouth on that
you know my mind was somewhere else now
and
i kind of did it because i was scared i
didn't know he gonna kill me or knock it
the way he was looking in his face
he had that that look like come on you
know what i mean
so i'm like what i'm supposed to do
so after i did well i
left ran out the garage
crying ran all the way home almost got
hit by a car
crying
my mama you looking at me like what's
wrong with you bro
i said uh i i don't know i can't
remember the dude's name
but he was a mexican guy i know that
that's what he was right
and i said his name and my mama said
what
he he had me put my mouth on this thing
right so my mom's like
oh hell no so she called her brother
terry
he come over and he asked me what
happened nephew
and i told him so we all go back across
the street
he was nowhere around to be seen he was
gone what not
so time going by
my step-dad do the same thing
but i i ain't put my mouth on this on
his penis
he always like to rub on my butt
you know what's the word but lessening
that's what he was doing to me
now this is a story that it happened to
me
from a child working my way up
to the age of 10 okay
after that happened
also uh my
my my english is kind of messed up i was
so hysterical
or something
well okay well anyway i was so scared
i'm trying well
hysterical hysterical okay yeah so
um i didn't know what to do
so i got to say
i'm the only child in my family i've got
the crime
crime i'm not knowing what to uh every
time i go to school i get in trouble
because
the the how feeling you see what i'm
saying
so i'm like wow this is crazy
when i was seven
when i was seven
i went over this lady house
and whenever i asked her you know
um her name is betty cheatham's
i go over her house and i ask her that
uh can i
can i do some kind of work you know me
like cut grass or something wash your
core
won't know whatever a hippie plant
she always give me a job but a lot of
times when i get up when
she get up and i ask can i use your
bathroom
i go she said yeah i go up in the
bathroom
leave the bathroom door up and whatever
you know what i mean
and do what i got to do when i come out
it just seemed like me sitting on the
couch together she asked me sit close to
her
when i was like seven right i guess she
was what
in her 30s or something at that time
and it it it it was just
a feeling that
after that happened for me in the garage
put my mouth on the penis or after you
know
things like that happened to me with my
step-dad
and things that happened to me
with this lady here i i didn't know what
to do
i didn't know what to say you know uh
by you being young like that your mind
you know
you're not thinking clearly you're not
you know
on that path that same path
the administration what i'm trying to
say is
the age is seven you're not on that page
your mind is somewhere else you know
what i mean like
scared scared type the thoughts
come out you know me thinking scared
so my mom she would take me to
um not a nursing home or something
to give revaluation
you know to check my buttons to check to
see if
you know anything's open what not
i you know i'm going through this pain
this situation by me being the only
child i didn't know what
i'm not knowing and understanding
anything
at that young age you know so
i'm i'm i'm just i i ain't really
too much i was ashamed by doing anything
with my friends when that happened to me
i was ashamed because i didn't want to
go play baseball with him
football you know
things like that as a sports you know
man when i was growing up
so now when i got about 12
13 years old
i see i go and spend like on my cousin's
house
and this is the same thing happened to
my cousin but she's a female
you know me and i've seen that when i
opened the door
i uh was he supposed to be the third
cousin
you know he had first second third
cousin
yeah he break my cousin and i'm standing
at the door
with tears in my eyes at 12 years old
then i run up out of there and go tell
my uncle charles
you know your brother's in there or
cousin whatever
in there nicky that's her name nicky
i've been through all that
now around the same
age this is lady she's a manager of
departments of down the venice
and she was out there
growing watermelon seeds watermelon
she planted watermelon seeds on the
ground okay
i'll go and then ask her her name's
madea
i like my dear is this possible
i can help you throw some seeds in there
she said sure come on precious
get down there this is what you do you
make the hole dig the hole
with the little shovel and put like
two or three seeds in the ground
so i was doing that my dear got tired
she was like 80 something years old at
that time and i was like
12. she got tired
went up in the house i'll be back
i'm go get some water she went up in the
house
i'm steady putting seeds in the ground
now ain't no more seeds on top of the
dirt because they're all in the hole
so i walk and and set up on the stairs
i'm sitting like
the way i'm sitting now looking down
a face came up off the ground on those
jesus the devil
what said
bobo would you like to work for me
i'm looking like i see a face
but i don't i don't know who this person
is
and i'm like no the face disappeared
that fast
so as it disappeared that fast i got up
and ran almost got hit by a car
so as i'm running out the gate
a car was coming and
i didn't see the car so i almost got hit
by a car when i ran
out the gate and the car skied
what not and i kept on running
as as i kept running
my mom and you know i'm in there crying
you know i was like scared
you know i wasn't a tough guy when i was
a kid
just scared you know the things that
happened to me
you know made me feel like that i was
what the bad guy or something or why i
gotta be me
why me all these things happen to me
you know so
down the line i
looks at things the older i get i see
how
my cousin is he's a homosexual
uh i got like three or four cousins
homosexuals i got a
cousin female they dice they
like mess with other women and
i sit there and watch and just be
looking at these
when we have a family and union thing
all the family come over
and i see he come dining he come up in
here with his boyfriend
oh this is my boyfriend such a sister
and i'm looking at him like wow
i mean the things that happened to me
should i be like that
i mean you know by him being my cousin
was he did he get right when he was a
child
so all of a sudden he's like that now
it's all
the things that went down with me when i
was a child
i don't too much speak about it because
i don't like to you know
do a man post a cry when he
knows that this happened to him and then
you can you
you're older now and then you all of a
sudden you feel
you know by talking about it you know
i'm saying you you know
cry i feel like i got tears in my eyes
right now
like i want to just dribble you know me
but
i don't know how i don't know how
because i guess the person i used to
carry
you know me
how did all this stuff all the sexual
abuse as a child
affect you as as a an adult right now
okay
be tell your truth be honest with you
uh uh i hate it
i hate it real tough i don't like to sit
next to a man
i don't know i don't care where i'm at
if a man sits here i get angry
i want to sit somewhere else okay
if i'm uh if i gotta uh if you ask me
get on a motorcycle with you
i won't do it that's what hot affects me
i get angry real mad if i'm sitting next
to another man
right now in a day i'm 55 years old
let me sit next to a man i'm getting up
i don't want to sit next to him
now not only that i got
it's so cold by the day after all that
happened to me
you know i mean i got
like what you calling them gay guys and
stuff
that's my friend now you know
but like i said i'm 55. i got gay guys
as my friend now
you know and
i go to their house or something to sit
down and be
looking and be thinking like wow
when i was a kid when i was younger i
didn't want to be
sitting next to no kid no another man
now i i i hit myself
in the house with with gay guys you know
what i mean
doing things but gang guys do
you know like say fancy
um dancing with them
you know i mean i have done that i'm
like man what
what i'm doing you know no no no no i
can't do that
you know i mean i'm tripping oh man i
got to go
this ain't this ain't my party this
ain't my picture this ain't my piece of
cake i'm on belongs here
you know i mean i caught myself doing
that
and uh
it's a trip man it's a trip hot things
you know you can't blame me on the world
blame yourself that's how i that's how i
look at it because
when i was young like that what i do
to be treated that way what i do to be
treated that way when i was young
when i'm a little older now it's like
now kind of skeptical to go up in that
house with them
no how can they do that but now when i
say oh
i seen my cousin his name is donny manny
you know having sex with another man i
seen that happen
know he called me over to deliver some
things
and that's what i did i went over there
knocked at the door knocked at the door
knock at the door
didn't want the answer go through the
window tapped on the window
the curtain is open you there he is
having sex in the bed
that threw me off they threw me off
like if i fell off the radical roller
coaster or something
you know i mean
it's like my family's messed up in the
head or something
you know me uh was i'm a bad guy
for me they had this happen to me
or what's going on with this family
why are all the mans just acting funny
you know stuff like that
but you know we got to live one day you
got to live
and stay strong you know
and you know
you're you born to be a man
you know and stay in a man place
got a little circle around stay in your
circle
be a man and keep walking forward
you know i mean trusting god
you know because i
i call i see myself going to church a
lot
you know i mean we all have bad things
we all have good things
but who are you going to serve you know
the lord
or satan um
joshua 24 15 said now if it seems evil
unto you the certain lord
choose you today who you'll serve
whether if my father sir was on the
other side of the flood
or my father and the amorites and who
would land
you dewell but after me and my house we
will serve the lord
and i want to say this um one more verse
and i hope everybody gets this verse
and hope you take heed of it
says john 14
chapter 1-5 let not your heart be in
trouble
believe in god believing also in me
in my father house of many matches if it
wasn't so i wouldn't have told you
i'll go prepare a place for you wherever
i go
a player play for you i'll come again to
see you unto myself
wherever i'm at yeah you be also i thank
god for all
your everybody in the world who's
looking at this on
youtube i i just ask you right now
keep your head up stay focused on god
amen
uh how did this affect your
relationships with women or
dogs okay no i i do have a wife
oh you do so you want me yeah yeah just
okay i i have not a problem oh
hmm okay
hmm well
to be honest with you uh
i myself you know
uh i'm into
i'm trying to i'm trying to i want i
want to bring the word
out my mouth the right way
you know not you know the words we use
on the streets
so uh you know i love making love to my
wife
you know it affects it it don't really
too much affect me it makes me
dismounted
be that man to my wife to make love to a
whole
everyday but she's not the type of
person that do it every day
but now oh here's another thing since we
run that up
i'm back with y'all again
you know when kids little kids around
you like little girls and stuff
and they see you and you know
oh they want to run or jump on your lap
little girl i don't know i can't do that
that's how that's how it affects me i
see a lot of guys
that pick up their daughter and let them
sit on their lap
you know and you know and stuff like
that i've seen that
but i can't do that i can't do that with
none of my
none of the girls in my family
you know if a baby laying there it's a
girl and he's crying
and somebody asked me oh go over there
pick up my daughter i'm not going to
pick up that dog
i'ma look around and call you hey man
come on
get this little girl is it because
you're attracted to her or just
you're just not comfortable i'm not
comfortable with what happened to me
when i was young yeah you didn't want
anything similar to it no
no i don't want i don't you know
because i hears a lot of things when
oh he's a rape list you know he's a you
know
child stuff you know i'll be here no no
no
i'm i'm good on that you know i mean
because in fact what happened to me
you've never had any kind of experiences
as an adult that are
no no no no no not too much because
not too much or not at all no
well i'mma say not too much because a
lot of times okay
at the time though i was just i didn't
really
too much i can't i just can't
when the kids come to me i'm like
all right i don't stop i punch the
brakes man you know you're walking up
too close
i don't care if you my niece my nephew
you walking up too close but i won't say
that to them though
i was like all right what you want wait
wait hold on
this hand goes here this hand go here
come on let me clap
clap then i'll play aloft with him and
be like so
you're afraid that something might
happen yeah with you yes
so you're you're very careful i'm very
careful to make sure it doesn't
yes sir and it never did it never did
good for you
never did in my lifetime never
because i'm i'm not going out backwards
i wish more people could do
what you did hey man brother i'm not
going out backwards
you know i mean good wasn't your fault
what happened to you as a kid no
no it wasn't my fault but uh
ah boy i like to knock crazy i like
to see him again but you know but i
don't know
you know god is good man all the time
all right amen brother thank you very
much yes sir